i
y
[Música]
sí
bien
y
[Música]
ah
i
[Música]
tan tan tan
tan tan tan tan tan tan
[Música]
tan tan tan tan tan tan tan tan
no tanto
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el tren
[Música]
ah
yo
[Música]
hola
chau chau
grado
job
buena manera
[Música]
que yo
[Aplausos]
claro
[Música]
wiki wiki
tan tan tan tan tan
[Aplausos]
[Risas]
ah
poco
guau oh guau guau
guau
[Aplausos]
o
ay
no
bebió una botella después otra botella y
que para borrarme
el dolor de consentir hace ya mucho
tiempo
te vengo por lo mismo
no estoy en borrachera por ti y que para
olvidarte por fin
pero que vanos de olvidos
pero como olvidarte si contamos más de
recuerdos y el licor engrandece tu
imagen y tenerte estas son dos mi pecho
dicen que tomando se me sigue y se
encuentra unido
pero en mi caso entre más borracho más
me duele que tú te hayas ido
y entregado a la pena
acabando y tan triste como pesa la vida
desde el día que te fui
ha cerrado el recuerdo embriagado y
dolido fue negando de mi soledad
estoy viviendo para olvidar
pero nada que olvido
como olvidarte si contamos más que
recuerdo de licores de tu imagen y
tenerte es más hondo en mi pecho
dicen que tomando se resiste y se
encuentra olvido pero en mi caso entre
más borracho me duele que tú
[Música]
tú
i
que haya sido
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero como olvidarte sin consejos para
este recuerdo si el licor en tres meses
tu imagen y te mete estás solo en mi
pecho
diferentes tomando
pero en mi caso
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tú
i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vi una botella después otra botella y
que para borrarme
el dolor de conciencia hace ya mucho
tiempo
te vengo por lo mismo
no estoy en boca yendo por ti y que para
olvidarte por fin
pero que vanos de olvido
pero como olvidarte si contamos más que
recuerdos de aquel licores grandes es mi
mano y te metes más hondo que yo
dicen que tomando se desiste y se
encuentra amigo
en mi caso entre más borracho más me
duele que tú te hayas ido
y entregado a la pena
acabado y tan triste y como pesa la vida
desde el día que te fui
ha cerrado el recuerdo embriagado y
dolido estoy negando de mi soledad
estoy viviendo para olvidar
pero nada que olvido
[Música]
olvidarte si contamos más que metiendo
y el licor en que antes de tu imagen y
te metes más hondo en mi pecho
dicen que tomando se resigne y se
encuentra olvido pero en mi caso entre
más borracho me duele que tú
[Música]
i
y ha sido
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero como olvidarte si con tragos para
este recuerdo si el licor emprende tu
imagen y te mete estas son dos hechos
diferentes
[Música]
pero mi caso
me duele
hola
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah no no
i
e
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]